How do I treat a toddler with ear infections?
Also how do I treat an infected, small, wound from a bird?
Okay.
Two questions.
So toddler with ear infections will historically try to educate parents because historically
people back in the 80s and 90s and early 2000s of their child.
They would go in for pediatric well checks and the doctor would look at child's ear and
whether the child had symptoms or not.
If you saw a full gene ear drum, they would say your child has an ear infection and
they would write a prescription for antibiotics.
They'd literally get antibiotics like candy for ear infections.
Many times it's a child that was pulling other ear and for complaining of ear pain, parents
would run to their pediatrician to get antibiotics for ear infections.
At least to argue, let's say trying to educate parents at that time because statistically
it's well documented that over 90% of ear infections in children are live viral.
Therefore antibiotics are going to work.
So antibiotics are only going to work on a bacterial infection.
It's not going to touch.
It's only going to do more damage than good so you don't use antibiotics.
So typically you're not going to go to antibiotics for ear infections.
But I do realize that while most ear infections will pass over time with no treatment needed
since its viral and viruses will run their course, some kids are prone to constant ear infections.
And that can be an issue.
Many times it's because of just genetically the shape of their ear canal and fluid tends
to puddle in there and they can end up with external ear infections that can lead to infections
of the drum.
Many times it can be some other underlighted cause giving them middle ear infections.
So what do you do?
So there are some natural things that you could do for external ear infections, external
needs, external to the drum and there's some natural things you could do for middle ear
infections.
The external ear infection, there's garlic oil, herb farm makes a good garlic oil that you
could drop, that you could put in a child's ear.
You could put hydrogen peroxide, 3% hydrogen peroxide in a child's ear to kill any external
ear infections.
So that would be also known as swimmer's ear.
If it's a middle ear infection, probably what this question is based on, then you want
to treat the child as far as building up their immune system to help them be able to deal
with viruses.
So things like vitamin C, zinc, echinacea, there's different liquid, herbal formulas that
are created for children that can help build their immune system and help them be able to
bite off viral infections.
Getting adjusted, going to a car parter, getting adjusted, their upper cervical adjusted can
be extremely helpful for children with ear infections.